ibm power 10 scale out mid-range servers
the ibm mq appliance m2003 and hyper
protect virtual servers for vpc all on
this episode of ibm tech now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
ibm technology
start things off this week ibm recently
announced a big expansion of its power
10 server line with the introduction of
three new mid-range systems and one
scale-out system
all built to modernize protect and
automate business applications and it
operations
the power 10 servers combine performance
scalability and flexibility with new
pay-as-you-go consumption offerings for
people looking to deploy new services
quickly across multiple environments
the new power 10 processor-based systems
are optimized to run mission-critical
workloads and maximize the efficiency of
containerized and cloud-native
applications
they'll also help you secure
infrastructure to defend against attacks
and automate operations to improve
productivity
these new servers join the popular power
10 e1080 server to deliver a secured
resilient hybrid cloud experience
to learn more about the new power 10
offerings check out the link i've got in
the description of this video
next up we've got the latest evolution
of the ibm mq appliance the m2003
ibm mq appliance acts as a messaging
center moving messages between
applications services and systems across
cloud and on-premises environments
and ibm mq solutions are used by
thousands of enterprises worldwide to
protect their data and deliver it to the
right place at the right time
the m2003 brings together next
generation hardware and ibm mq firmware
packed with the latest updates to
provide a more powerful appliance than
its predecessor
the m2003 is designed for simple setup
maximize performance business resiliency
cost efficiency data insights and
protection against threats
the ibm mq appliance m2003 will be
generally available august 2nd of this
year for more information hit the link
i've got below
to wrap things up for this episode let's
take a look at ibm hyper protect virtual
servers for vpc
this new offering is designed to protect
cloud native applications with open
container initiative deployments that
utilize confidential computing
this new product in the hyper protect
family is the next generation of hyper
protect virtual servers and a stepping
stone to a kubernetes-based offering
some of the key features include secure
execution multi-party contract and
attestation of deployment
malware protections bring your own oci
image and flexible deployments
using hyperprotect virtual servers for
vpc will help you with a variety of
strategic projects where security is the
underlying concern including
containerized workloads digital assets
and machine learning models
to learn more hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in tech now
you